the Joe Rogan experience who fight on
the beach who was that
he's gonna fight Google Duarte that's
right if you go to our day when I'm to
fight in Pride he fought tank Abbott
right man fought some different people
and I'm a man I remember that day was so
funny because you have a point on the
beach in Rio that is it's where most of
the issues where the pretty girls were
and all the guys are going data session
the beach very famous people and then
everybody go in that session and I'm we
keep you here that will go Charlie
Higson will coach Alan Hickson he'll go
challenge he's right there there we go
smack him in the face then he goes like
now he didn't say anything and I'm right
there I'm walking right there and light
Schwartz there my mission were Nixon
look up and look at me and say hey watch
my back where were you I'm the one okay
I'm off of the screen now right on on my
left you're gonna see me standing there
then oh he came right if you figure up I
can show you here is what you're this
man sometime in the eighties and don't
know who's filming that we have high and
Gracie
he was sitting someone shoulders with
fast camera crazy to try to see oh no
man I was getting so many bodies I was
getting on I was getting punched in the
head and the back just cause it's
watching Hickson's but everybody didn't
jump in no no no what we did was we made
a circle arms to arms and in Hickson's
one with the green shorts right green
strike yes and he had a long hair that
day which they got grabbed his hair
there's that long
oh no he it's a ponytail there really
yeah I knew he had a ponytail from a
lotta GOC now you see Hickson mounting
him
oh no he he got tired of punching the
guy we felt and so my mission him
punching him yeah there we go and the
guy tap and stop please stop and he has
a group of guys with him we want to make
sure that nobody jump in his bed
and then but the thing is we we have
this and don't get me wrong I'm not
telling people to go and do that but in
that time in that generation a lot of
those fights that happened in the street
was a need for jiu-jitsu to be
established the way should be and was
better than two guys fighting there then
that fight end up in a bar gang not
letting five people shooting each other
right in the remember Hickson said we we
get together our first original Gracie
by high school day and some members are
photo shoot to schools to say look guys
he's gonna go there I'm gonna make a
circle only him and the guy fight nobody
else fight you understand that because
if everybody fights then somebody's
gonna get really hurt because you're not
going to be able to control anything we
just made a big circle we'll hold hands
regardless of what happened we will not
interfere it takes another guy and
that's it but want to make sure nobody
jumps in they never make say you gotta
watch my back and I go like okay yeah
what his head don't do nothing I watch
my back and here we are I was behind him
and getting punch getting kicked from
other people but the crazy thing was
they happen and Hickson on his mind said
look I'm gonna go there slap him on the
face he's gonna run
then we're like okay he goes there slap
that guy and the guy did not run then we
go whole [ __ ] game on then we hold each
other and I think was this happened on
Saturday
Tuesday night Google went to Hickson
school with a lot of people they are all
carrying weapons Hickson wasn't there
and they call he shows up in shorts and
he quickly just slapped Boog around
somebody called the police later on and
they even shoot the ceiling he ar-15
whatever just boom and they left but
then was Hickson just smash him quick
this was on the cement not on the sand
but there again happen in a way for us
as a pride to prove the point is you do
too
the best of martial arts and we keep
going strong and you go was a little to
leave a guy who was a little iffy
respected real strong one of the best
guys to today and they had a grappling
style it just wasn't as comprehensive
back there they were doing a lot of foot
locks already yeah you're the ones that
are doing a lot of foot locks and oogie
a lot of huge yeah and they have some
quality fighters among with them
definitely your general Tadeo or janitor
deal and they have I end up fighting one
of the guys from there and now one of
the Abu Dhabi's there but as the time
goes by I think people get older can
understand and I don't think today has
any conflict or any bad feelings and
they must have adopted a lot of the
jujitsu techniques to everything
magicians yeah take the deal right today
I love training grappling okay what is
the definition of grappling the
underground fighting then it's jiu-jitsu
[Applause]